tu vois de l'autre la dictature c'est
pas lisse annoncé pour la réunion
parents d'élèves je pourrais jamais y
être a peut-être est-on baby sitter faut
y aller un nom ça se mange tellement
elle maîtrise bonjour bonjour monsieur
canova j'imagine marguet france en
mariage je porte mon amer d'accord j'y
vas pas voir bienvenue
l'agent suisse ont peur elle m'a dit les
parents qu'il fallait commencer ce lundi
matin et le nom de l'association des
parents d'élèves c'est pas obligatoire
voilà je pense que j'ai tout dit c'est
pour ma fille myriam crie parce que là
on est sur suspicion tron alimentaire
elle mange que du mouvement que d'humour
vous avez détesté
je peux aller faire pipi est ce que tu
peux attendre le pardon pardon qui est
disponible au le vendredi piscine
vincent je peux rien moi je fais pas
piscine pas de sortie pascual bon je
vous préviens le premier qui fait une
réflexion sur mon moule [ __ ] je dois
racing 5 dès le départ c'est franchement
ça servira jamais up pièce un rendez
vous individuels avec la maîtresse lycée
pour rencontrer les parents et par lé
nounours et en tête à tête
42 bizarre de vous voir dans la vraie
vie c'est tout à fait normal
le tennis coule par son bénéfice de la
coopérative souvient téléphonique usa 10
julien irène crottes
olé
j'adore
aujourd'hui vous êtes un super papa
alors il est comment cette maîtresse
canon compétentes quoi bon
[Musique]